These are the glasses that will let you see and do things that you
would have never imagined yourself doing while sitting in
your place. These are VR glasses, or
virtual reality, through the presence of the screen in front of your
eyes. With time, they completely separate from the place
you are sitting in, and you remain truly present, with
pure history, controlling everything.  In front of you through the
glasses or directly in your hands.
Today's video I will talk to you about these glasses and
how they can be used in the professional or
professional aspect of entertainment. And most importantly of all, this is
the motivation that made me make this video to
tell you about the dangers of these glasses, especially if
you are a father or mother and have  My sons and daughters are
concerned about the issue of these glasses and we want them as soon as
possible. It is necessary to know what dangers the
glasses can cause. This issue is much farther than what you
imagine. Let us begin. Peace be upon you. Omar Mohsen is coming to you today from the house that will introduce us to the virtual world. Sorry, you have seen me
a lot in glasses. Of course, the topic of
freshness.  This has been around for a long time in the days of
pilot simulators. If you had the chance to go,
for example, to ride the simulator plane and experience
Arabic shopping, changing it, and all these things, but
the quality that exists in VRD is
completely different from the simulator, and therefore it makes you
completely separate from the world that you want to feel that
you are in.  A parallel world. The idea of ​​these glasses
is simply a screen, and this screen contains speakers that
can make you feel that you are inside this place. I
mean, the headphones, without even installing a headset inside your
head, you feel that you are hearing everything as if you were
exactly in the place in front of you and controlling everything I
told you about.  These wheels are
similar to the Playstation wheels, but you can also
leave them completely behind and control them with your fingers like this,
as you can see in this video. I was
controlling everything on the screen in front of me with my fingers, and the
nice thing about it is that there are no cables that you ca
n't connect to a computer or to Play.  It
was a station in the old days. It must have been
difficult to connect it to a computer or not. You only had to
wear it once, and the matter
ended like that. Of course, there are still other VR glasses that you can
connect to and give you.
Of course, there is higher quality in these games and things, but
I am talking about something whose price is not
comparable to the rest.  The VR is high, and at the same time you
wear it directly without any cables. Of course, there are
very many companies that manufacture VR, like the companies
in front of you. Once you open the device, it logs you in as if you were logged in
to Facebook. When you log in with the same
username you have on Facebook and enter the
house, this house is the one you choose.  You have a
set of fixed shapes to choose from, or for sure in the
future the issue will be deeper than that.
In a mirror, as you see in this mirror, you
can see yourself in it, you can see your hands in it, you can
see everything in it, and of course there will be
sound effects depending on whether
or not the place you are in exists in its magic.  Or you
are in a house or you are in the mountain. You hear a sound
like this, soft like that, which takes you inside the place. Ok, how do you
control it? And if you want to write something, you want to
consult everything through the dials. You
consult on something you want and write. The
keyboard opens for you as you see it
and write.  Whoever you want or consult with your fingers,
now that I have opened the basic game, he
will teach you how to use shields, and at the same time, this is the
most fun thing I can do.
This is the virtual one. I can do it with my hands, and I can leave it a lot, and it is very fun. I can sit and play like this with both hands. This paper pilot, I don’t
know how to fly or fly.  What else,
of course, now
[Music] A
beautiful box so far. What are the uses? You told
us that there are still professional uses and
uses for entertainment. Entertainment is clear to us
about games like this
[Music]
but it really makes you fear the inside of the game to the point that
if you are tired, you will not feel it.  It makes you tired except when you raise your
glasses. I mean, you can hold the gun, hit
it, hold a toy while you are holding it, and the
shield remains in it. This makes you feel that you are actually holding this thing in front of you. Of course I did. There will be no feeling for you except when you hold it yourself. Believe me, I mean, I am trying to convey the feeling, but it is not easy. The topic is me, if
anyone.  He said to me in R: I will tell him, brother, these glasses were in the old
days, which were just for seeing
3D things and you didn't know what, and that's not it. It's a big topic. It makes
you live the entire experience as if you were exactly
in the field of games. It's fun to the point of imagining it. If any
child or young person without children would not use
this product.  I don't think he'll leave her alone, I mean, the flirt
on the mobile phone, which I see, of course, for
sure, many children are addicted to this topic. I can't imagine how they would stay with VR, because they are
actually
living. Where is their place? And sometimes you
feel that this place is better than the reality that you are living in. There is a
picture that I saw in the old days.  He's sitting there
frustrated and wearing glasses, very realistic.
I mean, okay, let's go back to the topic for more about the
luxury. I told you about games and there's nothing more than them.
Movies are done now. Animation of VR movies is like you're exactly inside
the movie. You can watch
things that aren't all on one screen that rotates
every 360 degrees and sees the things along with it.  There are
audio connectors and there is some air coming out of the sides here of the glasses.
As you can see, this is my
space and the YouTube valley that I watch. I see everything
here. If we open a video like this, a
video. I am inside the clouds now. It is
like I am inside the plane. Literally everything
here is a road.  What is in front of me is, and it is certain that there
will also be films that will be made in VR, of course, you can watch them, but the
screen is a little close, but in VR, things move in front of
you and roll with them. You see them
in their place. The sound, instead of being here, comes to your mind. The other one is
not just a
screen that is getting closer and becomes in your eyes, and that's it.
Here are previous videos or that you can use
OneCard via Fawry Fawry if you are in Egypt,
so click on and click on. The step after that is
simple and
it will give me the PayPal account. I put my account in and buy a copy and an email will come to me and
I enter the account here through
my membership and click on  So,
here I will find the copy of Windows that I have. I will click
on it to show me the copy of Windows that I
purchased. After that, I can take a number and put it in the copy of
Windows. I also saw it on some of
the games that are available in Evil Tab being played. You
will find singers and people who do not know what
you are inside the place,
and of course.  In the case of sports games, you sit playing
sports games and of course you see things that motivate you. As
you continue bouncing and playing things like this, you actually forget
yourself. I mean, it is very fun in the field of sports. You
also see how many miles you have moved, and
all these things are in the professional field. How can it be if you
have, for example, a company in need?  Some customers
go to a factory, pick up tools, solve problems,
and a complete simulation model can be made for them. You have these glasses available in one
or more places, and they start trying out
these things and holding them on their own, exactly as if they were holding them. The
real thing is not yours. No, you can
imagine things that will be rich.  But Heidi is
very high and makes you actually simulate reality, so it will help you and
save you the costs of the matter. Meetings, if there is
more than one person in more than one country in
different places, each one with the glasses can actually
see what is in front of him with all his movements and all his
expressions. He can draw and see what he is
doing right now in front of them, I mean, not  Just a
video of Cole showing what it looks like and that's it, all the
movements that you write and make are visible to
everyone and thus it will be more effective than
zoom meeting or all of these things. If you are an
architect, for example, and you want to show the client what the
apartment will look like after you finish it, it is very difficult with a few
pictures to see, but if  He entered the place and saw
the video of the window, for example, or the balcony, and at the
same time around him, he saw
how the floors were treated, the colors of the walls, and all of these things
would be realistic and able to convince the customer of them. In the
field of marketing, I have seen many websites that
currently operate a metaverse, web sites, through which you can
get inside the store and see their products.
What is something that you can see and make an
immediate decision? The last thing about the application is that it is exactly the
same. There are a
large number of official ones that she owns, that she is the one who
made these glasses, and there is another
unofficial store called the mobile phone model. Exactly what do
you have on the mobile phone or on the computer? You can
also put things in it.  VR, the bottom line of the matter is that
in the future you will find these glasses are a
normal thing. All people have glasses, exactly like mobile phones.
I expect their weight will definitely be less,
because of course their size is a little larger with time and the
long run feels a little painful, I mean, in the partial,
but more. It is very enjoyable. You can’t imagine how much fun it would be while
I  With the video product,
Apple announced its glasses for
virtual and augmented reality. This is a
clear indication that this technology is no longer
limited to limited companies, but we expect that
it will spread everywhere and all companies will begin to
compete strongly and produce similar products at
lower prices. Therefore, sooner or later,
glasses like this will be expected.  This will be present in your house. The person in
front of you will be able to see you, see your eyes,
and interact with you, and you will be able to see with natural vision in
colors. At the same time, the device will activate the
housing around you. Therefore, when you talk to someone, a
video call will be able to see you as if you are not wearing glasses that do not
have shields, and you can control it with your hands, not like a dead one, and its
battery is dead.  It is separate so that it is more
comfortable to wear and therefore you can wear it for a long time. It has
eye movement sensors so that you can choose between
applications just by looking. You can also
take videos and photos through it. To be honest, they have very many features. Secondly, if you are interested, write to me below in the comments so that I can make a detailed video
about it for you. How many days is it?  Meta or Facebook
announced its new glasses when it comes to Quest 3. The
most important and biggest danger of VR glasses, I think, is that
with time you will feel that
these glasses or this virtual reality is much better
than the reality you want. I am
very confident that it will greatly affect your health.
Psychology is just a topic, not a joke. Of course, I will not tell
you how the issue will be affected by
children. They do not have sufficient awareness of how to
stop using this device or the time
allowed for them to operate it. Therefore, I do not
advise anyone to get this VR for anyone who is
young, and if it happens and you have it, be  Be very careful when you
use it on a personal level. Focus on the time
because you really will not feel the time completely. The third thing I have seen
more than one eye doctor talking about this topic is that it is exactly as if you put the
mobile phone
very close to your eye and there is a certain lens that
makes you able to see this thing in a clear and clear way.
Because if you put the mobile phone in front of me, you will see that your
eyes are done like this, allowing the eyes to dry. Get off it and do not catch it. For this reason, it
was advised that you
use a 2020 roll of
glasses on you and you look at the place far away and you can close it. You open
your eyes for the sake of the cornea, but I do not
know how this will happen. To be honest, 20 minutes is a little
expensive.  This steals time, but Diet was his
advice: If you are not used to something like this
at first, you will feel dizzy and unbalanced, especially if you
turn on something like, for example, or turn on something like, for example, Spider-
Man who is flying and you find yourself
flying while you are in your place. You will find your whole body seeing you
flying while you are in it.  Your position in the subject
causes some smoke. Of course, as soon as you
use it, it tells you to put the edges in the place
you are in. It is necessary to draw. Of course, he comes up to you and asks you that you
must put the edges. If you are sitting in
my place, he tells you that you are sitting or you draw your own edges.
These edges are the space
in which you move.  While you are using VR, if you do not
adhere to the theme of space in some games, you push yourself, you may trip over someone.
You will trip yourself and
run while you do not see what is in front of you. That's it. Get down. Get down, my son. Go downstairs.
With the first or second minute, it will be completely disconnected. But I
wish you safety for you and your children, and I will see you later.
God willing, there will be a new video. May God’s peace, mercy, and blessings be upon you